là où ça bouge de somme à salo ce soir
pour les rendez vous soniques 38
concerts jusqu'à samedi soir dont le
premier ici même à la salle beaufils
avec une femme que vous connaissez si je
vous fais cet indice la avec l'aide de
mes complices attention
avec dans la loge ici même à la salle
beaufils c'est pas la première fois que
vous venez à saint-lô n'en connaissez
bien cette ville non là c'est là ce soir
c'est la troisième fois j'étais venu en
première partie de délices au normandy
et l'année dernière au rendez vous
soniques avec coeur de pirate en
première partie aussi en normandie
ça veut dire que nicolas d'aprigny
l'organisateur a eu le nez car depuis ça
marche très fort
vous avez pris la grosse tête entre
temps oui je viens ce que j'ai commencé
quand j'avais 16 ans donc voilà j'ai
travaillé pendant sept ans sur la
composition de cet album est donc on a
le temps de beaucoup réfléchir du coup
beaucoup penser à ce qu'on veut montrer
aux gens aussi et j'ai la chance d'être
très bien entouré donc c'est ça qui met
les plots 6
la rythmique en général c'est quelque
chose qui m'a influence énormément parce
que c'est par là que j'ai commencé j'ai
fait des cours de batterie après les
faits des cours de derbouka c'est une
percussion arab à dubai et donc c'est ça
un peu le fil conducteur aussi de cet
album bien le bûcher l'ouest toulouse et
pau et en 9 ans je suis partie à dubaï
pour présent donc c'est là bas que j'ai
appris les percussions arabe
après j'ai vécu quatre ans à pointe
noire c'est une petite ville au sud du
congo brazzaville et après j'ai passé
mon bac à abu dhabi et je suis revenu
vivre à paris pour faire une prépa en
large ce qui est important de dire
puisqu'on voit cet album ce qui va être
édité le 25 novembre avec cinq inédits
avant vous retourniez encore aux etats
unis c'est vous dire si ça marche très
très fort pour cent qu'est ce que vous
allez offrir ce soir au public de saint
lô batoul album et faire la fête c'est
une bonne idée
ouais on va revenir ici tout à l'heure
pour parler de domme l'anena la première
partie de jane mais pour l'instant
direction mondeville pour retrouver
patrick mertz et son sourire de légende
charmeur 10ème édition du festival
mondeville sur rire c'est parti pour une
semaine d'humour a eu le temps on en a
bien besoin
sur noël c'est parti pour une semaine de
franche rigolade on espère en tout cas
on espère que les gens vont rire et vont
apprécier le programme les temps forts
le temps forts dont qui à la soirée
anniversaire le 10 et le gars là le 11
mais c'est sûr pas
pendant six ans
alors les têtes d'affiché dont didier
super sur la scène utopique frédérick
sigrist le collègue d'anne roumanoff
oldelaf avec alain berthier pour le
spectacle la folle histoire de michel
bantam a et kevin razy a aussi été
bercée par les dessins animés américain
c'est ce qu'ils souhaitaient de notre
gueule tu sais du genre denver le
dernier dinosaure les gars nous ont fait
croire que des gamins de 15 ans pouvait
trouver dans la rue un dinosaure de sept
mètres de haut
on peut dire aussi qu'en normandie voilà
à l'humour a encore un beau sinon à
tracer parce qu'il n'ya pas en pas
grandes propositions et que du coup bas
on constate que le public est vraiment
présent des idées qu'il a la possibilité
de devenir ben voilà c'est qui a été un
peu rire pour les gens qui disent bon au
lieu de voile à la peine de mort fut
pour les gens qui font les puzzles de
5000 pièces ça on est là pour les gens
qui font des infos sur ma chanson là
pour les gens qui te dit ça va comme
lundi l'appel
retour à saint lô pour aller au brésil
oui je suis brésilien luiz est ce dieu
que j'écrive en fait j'ai je suis né au
brésil j'ai grandi un peu en france est
passé mon adolescence en argentine donc
je chante surtout en portugais en
espagnol en fait c'est gonflé parce que
là vous avez un seul instrument votre
voix magnifique et vous y aller comme ça
c'est complet oui là je suis en soft en
général je pleins d'autres d'instruments
autour de moi je joue là c'est la
version lite mais oui j'ai voulu faire
ce faire ce projet tout seul sur scène
le festival rendez vous soniques
continue jusqu'à samedi à saint louis